Traductor: Judit Rodríguez
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Pensad en una mujer de vuestro entorno.
Puede ser vuestra madre, vuestra hermana
vuestra abuela, la vecina del quinto...
La que sea.
¿La tenéis?
Vale, ahora imaginad que llega un día
y os dice que se va a viajar sola.
¿Qué pensáis?
Igual algunos pensáis: "Pero ¿sola?
¿Es que no tiene amigas o
un marido, un novio con el que irse?"
Habrá quien piense:
"Pero eso es muy peligroso...
es que te pueden raptar,
te van a violar, te van a matar". ¿No?
Seguro que muchos
habéis pensado algo de esto.
Son dos de las reacciones más típicas
que la gente tiene
cuando les digo que viajo sola.
Si hace 4 o 5 años me hubierais preguntado
si viajaría sola
os hubiera dicho que no,
que eso no era para mí.
Es que ni me lo había planteado
porque me parecía
quizá aburrido, incluso peligroso.
Pero todo cambió hace unos 3 años y medio
que algo me hizo clic
y decidí dejar mi rutina de casa
al trabajo y del trabajo a casa
por algo un poco más aventurero.
Así que me compré una mochila,
un billete de solo ida de avión
y me fui a viajar sola
por Sudamérica durante 6 meses.
Y sí, por supuesto me dijeron
que me iba a pasar de todo,
que si no tenía amigas con las que irme,
porque probablemente pensaron
lo que estáis pensando vosotros:
que para no habérmelo planteado,
encima me voy a Sudamérica,
con lo peligroso que es, ¿verdad?
Pues más allá de todos esos
prejuicios que tenemos
lo que me encontré allí, en realidad,
fue gente maravillosa,
paisajes alucinantes,
me lo pasé pipa
y además descubrí que el mundo
no es tan peligroso
como nos quieren hacer creer.
La verdad es que tanto en aquel viaje
como en muchos otros que he hecho sola,
me podía haber pasado de todo,
porque hago cosas arriesgadas
que obviamente, en mi día a día no hago.
Por ejemplo aquí, estoy
debajo de un glaciar, en Argentina,
y quizás se podía haber caído encima de mí
pero no pasó nada.
También me fui a Perú, al Amazonas,
y ahí estuve durmiendo durante 3 noches
en un campamento,
al aire libre, con una pared
que era una mosquitera.
Tuve en mis manos
boas constrictor, caimanes,
un montón de animales
que me podían haber incluso comido,
pero no me pasó nada.
El año pasado también me fui a Perú,
a Vietnam, perdón,
y allí logré cruzar las calles de Hanói
sin que me atropellara ninguna moto,
y si habéis estado en Vietnam,
sabéis de lo que hablo,
que eso es un caos.
También me fui a Canadá,
hace un par de años.
Me fui a las montañas rocosas
a hacer senderismo sola,
porque me gusta mucho caminar.
Y claro, todo el mundo me decía:
"Pero ten cuidado con los osos".
Pues sigo esperando a ver un oso
y de hecho,
me hubiera encantado ver alguno,
pero lo único que vi
fueron paisajes como este.
Al final siempre me dicen
que me puede pasar de todo viajando sola
pero lo peor que me ha pasado
ha sido que me robaron la tablet en Perú,
y ni siquiera fue un asalto,
es que la dejé en una mochila sin candado
y obviamente cuando volví, ya no estaba.
Pero es que,
a quién se le ocurre, ¿verdad?
Son cosas que te pasan allí,
pero también te pasan aquí,
porque, por ejemplo,
viví en Alemania unos años,
consideramos que es un país seguro
y me robaron la cartera dos veces,
y cuando vivía en Madrid,
en mi época de estudiante,
una noche, al ir a entrar al portal
me pegaron un tirón al bolso.
Así que después de tener
estas experiencias negativas
tanto fuera como dentro de mi país,
hay una cosa que no logro entender
y además me molesta muchísimo,
y es que me llamen valiente
cuando viajo sola.
Porque a ver, cuando he dicho:
"Pensad en una mujer de vuestro entorno
se va a viajar sola",
¿cuántos de vosotros habéis pensado
que esa mujer es una valiente?
A ver, levantad la mano, que os vea.
¿Veis? Sois un montón.
(Ríe)
Y no sois los únicos, porque mirad,
el año pasado creé mi proyecto
"Quiero viajar sola",
es una comunidad de mujeres
en la que nos ayudamos entre todas un poco
a vencer esos miedos
acerca de viajar en solitario,
y como no encontré
demasiada información en Internet
de estadísticas sobre viajar sola,
creé mi propia encuesta.
Así que pregunté a la gente
por qué viaja sola, por qué no
que preocupaciones tiene,
que piensan de la gente
que viajamos solos,
¿y adivináis lo que dijeron?
Pues sí.
Muchos de ellos dijeron
que somos valientes.
Pero esta vez no me enfadé
(Ríe)
cuando me lo dijeron,
sino que me lo tomé como un cumplido
y mezclé ese 26 % de valentía
con el 8 % que dijo
que somos independientes,
el 8 % que dijo que nos admiran,
los que dijeron que somos personas
seguras de nosotras mismas,
libres, aventureros,
simpáticos, abiertos...
Y al final con tanto piropo dije:
"Joer, los que viajamos solos
y solas somos la leche".
¿No?
(Aplausos)
Parece que seamos
superhéroes o superheroínas
pero ¿a que no veis a la gente
yéndose en masa a viajar por ahí?
¿A que no?
De hecho, ¿cuánta gente conocéis
que viaje solo o sola?
¿A que muchas veces los podéis contar
con los dedos de una mano?
Es que hay mucha gente que,
directamente, no se lo plantea,
porque prefiere viajar con otras personas.
Por ejemplo, de la gente
que contestó en la encuesta
que nunca había viajado sola,
dos tercios de los hombres
y la mitad de las mujeres
dijeron precisamente esto.
Pero más allá de que la gente
no se lo plantee,
hay muchos miedos
alrededor de viajar en solitario.
Y es que, por ejemplo,
2 de cada 10 mujeres
no viajan solas porque tienen miedo
de que les ocurra algo malo.
Otra de cada 10 tiene miedo
de que le ocurra algo malo
y además no saber cómo reaccionar
ante una situación adversa.
La gente que viaja sola
también tiene sus preocupaciones,
por ejemplo, que les roben,
tener un accidente, enfermarse...
Pero una de cada 10 mujeres que viaja sola
tiene miedo de sufrir una violación.
Y muchas veces es nuestro propio entorno
el que nos contagia un poco estos miedos,
porque 3 de cada 10 mujeres dijeron
que su entorno había reaccionado
con miedo, con preocupación,
cuando les dijeron
que se iban a viajar solas.
Y al final, ¿qué nos dicen estos datos?
Pues que el miedo
está asociado a viajar sola,
en femenino,
y nos dice también que
hay cierta desigualdad de género
en el mundo de los viajes también.
Porque no percibimos igual
que una mujer viaje sola
a que un hombre viaje solo.
Pero ¿por qué es esto?
Cada cierto tiempo vemos en las noticias
precisamente noticias de mujeres
que viajaron solas
y que fueron asesinadas.
Y no solo solas, sino que, por ejemplo,
dos chicas argentinas
se fueron a Ecuador de vacaciones
y fueron asesinadas.
Todo el mundo dijo que iban solas,
porque eran dos. Chicas.
No había ningún hombre
que las protegiera de aquel destino.
También aquí en España fue muy sonado
el caso de Denise,
una turista estadounidense
que fue asesinada
cuando hacía el Camino de Santiago.
Claro, vemos estas noticias
de gente que se va a viajar sola fuera
y pensamos que el mundo es peligrosísimo,
nos va a pasar de todo.
Pero es que si nos quedamos en casa,
también hay cositas así.
Porque, por ejemplo, cada cierto tiempo
en las mismas noticias
vemos casos de mujeres
que salieron al supermercado, por ejemplo,
y no volvieron, como Laura Luelmo,
muy reciente.
O de chicas que salieron de fiesta
y cuando volvían solas a su casa
fueron asesinadas, como Diana Quer,
o chicas que fueron a resolver
un problemilla con su exnovio
y su cuerpo nunca jamás se encontró,
como Marta del Castillo.
Llevamos pocos días de este 2019
y ya han sido 8 las mujeres asesinadas
por sus parejas o exparejas.
47 el año pasado.
Casi 1000 desde que hay registros.
¿Sabéis qué?
Que el lugar más inseguro para una mujer
es su propia casa,
y no lo digo yo, lo dice la ONU.
En el año 2017, de las casi 87 000 mujeres
asesinadas en todo el mundo,
el 58 % fueron asesinadas
por un hombre de su entorno,
un hombre que conocían.
Así que si nos vamos
a la otra punta del mundo
es peligrosísimo y nos va a pasar de todo,
pero es que si nos quedamos en casa,
también nos están matando.
Entonces, ¿por qué ponemos tanto empeño
en que lo de fuera es mucho más peligroso
que lo que tenemos alrededor?
La sociedad es como que
trata de protegernos
por el hecho de ser mujeres,
como que nos mete en una cajita de cristal
desde que nacemos.
Y no podemos salir,
porque todo es peligroso.
No hables con desconocidos, no vayas aquí,
no vayas allá, ¿verdad?
Y lo malo es que
lo tenemos tan interiorizado
que no nos damos cuenta
que estamos en esa cajita.
Lo bueno es que
estamos empezando a despertar
y a decir basta.
Basta de tanta violencia contra la mujer,
basta de cuestionar
cualquier cosa que hagamos,
basta de ponernos límites
que nosotras no queremos tener.
Y al final, gracias a que
estamos despertando,
estamos empezando a conocer casos
de gente que viaja sola
y de chicas que viajamos solas,
y por ejemplo, yo lo cuento
en mi blog, pero somos más.
Y no somos pioneras,
sino que antes de nosotras
hubo muchas otras.
Os presento a Egeria.
Ella en el siglo IV se fue
hasta Tierra Santa peregrinando
y cruzó tres continentes,
más de 25 000 km
y está considerada la primera peregrina
y viajera de la historia
porque dejó constancia de sus aventuras.
Nellie Bly. Ella era periodista
y le propuso a su editor
dar la vuelta al mundo,
replicando a Phileas Fogg, el personaje
de "La vuelta al mundo en 80 días",
que a este seguro que le conocéis,
y su editor le dijo que no,
porque era 1889
y no estaba bien visto
que una mujer pudiera hacer algo así.
Así que ella lo retó:
se fue a otro diario
y consiguió que la apoyaran,
pero además dio la vuelta
al mundo sola en 72 días.
Ella es Amelia Earhart.
Está considerada un referente
en el mundo de la aviación,
porque fue la primera mujer
en cruzar sola el océano Atlántico
pilotando un avión, en 1932.
Y si algo nos dicen todas estas mujeres
es que si ellas hicieron estas hazañas
cuando no tenían móviles,
no tenían mapas precisos,
no tenían casi ni derechos,
entonces todas nosotras podemos hacerlo.
Si es que hoy en día
es muy fácil viajar sola
y además hay muchísimas
mujeres viajando solas.
No os hacéis a la idea, de verdad.
Hay miles.
Y algunas llevan años viajando,
otras igual se están subiendo a un avión
precisamente en este momento,
para viajar solas.
Igual van con muchos miedos
y preocupaciones,
pero también van con mucha ilusión,
porque tienen ante sí un gran reto
y quieren demostrarse a sí mismas
que son capaces de hacerlo.
Yo siempre animo a todo el mundo
a que viaje solo o sola
porque, creo que es
una de las experiencias más maravillosas
que hay en la vida.
Te acercas mucho más
a la cultura que estás conociendo,
a la gente local,
a quien te rodea,
aprendes a tomar decisiones,
te vuelves mucho más independiente,
te sientes libre,
descubres lo que te hace feliz.
Y, sí, estamos de acuerdo,
pueden pasar cosas malas,
pero hay muchísimas más
cosas buenas que malas
esperando ahí fuera.
Y viajar, al final no es más que salir
a ver el mundo con tus propios ojos,
salir a la calle,
y por eso me molesta tanto
que me llamen valiente,
porque cuando viajo sola,
lo único que estoy haciendo
es salir a la calle sola
y tenemos que normalizar
el hecho de que la gente,
sobre todo las mujeres, viajemos solas
porque no podemos quedarnos
para siempre en la cajita de cristal
porque lo de fuera nos de miedo.
Es que así no vamos a cambiar las cosas.
Así que la próxima vez que alguien te diga
que se va a viajar solo o sola,
por ejemplo, esa mujer que vino
a vuestra mente al principio de la charla,
no le digáis que es valiente,
no le digáis que está como una cabra,
no le metáis miedos en la cabeza,
porque ya probablemente tiene muchísimos,
simplemente apoyadla.
Viajar solo es una experiencia
maravillosa, de verdad.
Y cuando viajamos solos,
no solo crecemos muchísimo personalmente,
sino que además estamos contribuyendo
a que el mundo sea
un poquito mejor cada día,
un poquito más igualitario, más justo,
y ojalá entre todos y todas,
dentro de poco, salir solos a la calle,
en cualquier calle del mundo,
sea cosa de personas libres
y no de personas valientes.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)